Throughout history, color has always been associated with the emotions found in humans.
In the West, people are green with envy, feel blue,...
...or view the world through rose - colored glasses;
others are purple with fury, or tickled pink.
In both east and west, to be "in the pink" means to be healthy.
One of the most fascinating aspects to color researchers...
...was the difference in color perception among people in various parts of the world.
Red apples, yellow bananas and blue sky...
...or natural human memory color's meanings remain unchanged.
All other colors; however, may be interpreted differently.
With skin tones, the meaning of color changes.
When Asians, Europeans, and Americans are asked what skin should look like...
...the answer was the same- "healthy".
However, how people define "healthy" changes between cultures.
In America and Europe, a tan makes you look healthy.
But when someone in Asia was asked about "American tan" as a color the answer was,...
..."Well, that person looks drunk."
In Asia, beauty images are always very white - skinned, and very pale.
Today, however, these color standards are starting to merge together...
...due to global media and the standardization of beauty around the world.
How does the printer get skin color mostly right?
Remember when you first bought your computer,...
...and it prompted you for your country of residence and language?
Your printer uses your answers to determine your color preferences...
...so that everyone's skin color looks "healthy".